hi guys I'm here in Prague with lovey
loader and Anton you know des and the
doggy
we people don't know Anthony once again
we already made a video but Anthony Cruz
yourself yeah I'm an English guy living
in Prague I have a YouTube channel he
says for fluent and check it talks about
learning Czech and languages in general
he's a pretty cool guy makes wonderful
videos about language learning so check
the check anyway we talked about before
we talked about speaking fluently and
you said something that really caught my
eye in my ear so to say the fact in
order to speed you have to you have to
speak right but a lot of people are
scared of speaking so can you tell me a
little bit about that your experience
work yeah I've noticed lots of people
say I'm afraid to look stupid I'm afraid
of speaking and how do I get over the
fear and this is a really important
thing to me because you can get over
fear in one of two ways I I discovered
mmm-hmm the first one is to be brave you
should pay yourself and you try not to
blush and you feel nervous and shake and
you do your best and you come away a bit
embarrassed you think that was
unpleasant that I want to do that again
and I did that many times and all it did
was so you were like yeah I can do that
exactly
I then was another game but this so this
is the heroic way of facing fear but
what I discovered actually works for me
was understand why I was afraid and it
was because I was worried did the person
I was speaking to would think I was an
idiot that they would think I was faking
that I didn't know the language very
well yes it would check recheck yeah and
well but okay with check so I thought
these people are gonna think I'm stupid
they can I think my level of check is
rubbish when I was just starting out and
I just realized well my level of check
is rubbish they would be accurate but so
what my goal is not to impress them is
to communicate to get the message across
when I accepted that when he accepted
the reality I wasn't afraid anymore so I
went in knowing that my goal wasn't to
impress them but rather to communicate
and with that in mind I judged the
conversation not on whether they thought
how is greater whether I was using fancy
words at the height of my vocabulary but
rather whether the communication worked
now this this is all this is what it's
all about
do you have a like okay you're talking
about what happened to you do you have
anybody in mind to which this happened
like yeah I was telling look at this
story about a friend of mine who'd been
studying Czech very intently for years
and she had a massive recovery but she
said to me I just can't really say
anything not even comes even with a few
words so I said that's because you're
wanting to impress them with all these
big fancy words I want it instead to be
about making communication happen and
accomplishing goals so with me you
should go out not just for the purpose
purpose of showing up book for the
purpose of making something happen so I
took her into the city center and said I
want you to go to this ice cream shop
asked to sample three or four different
flavors of ice cream before choosing the
one you wanted oh well yes she do you go
my super can't really we'll just have a
little practice on simple things like
saying well excuse me I know my check
isn't perfect what I'd like to say can I
please try some different ice creams
blah blah blah and the center aisle
whenever I mean five minutes later she
was skipping up the street holding an
ice cream and she said that was an
exhilarating experience yeah yeah it was
not about the words
he was just about the the act of
communication was like public the public
and private victory yeah it was because
she no longer was worrying about will I
look good
will I sound fantastic but rather will I
now be able to accomplish some goal
something make something happen that I
had never been known to do before and
that was have a communication with these
ice creams and samples and blamers and
he gave it a confidence then that she
could do it again so people like this is
the point people don't like confidence a
they [ __ ] light quarters we're hoarders
they collect words but they actually
don't go and use them so you can
actually collect words for the rest of
your life but if you don't talk it's
never gonna happen it's great
vocabulary but he isn't going to help
your conversational ability so I say you
can build this such a framework of
communicative ability with a very small
vocabulary
I would next estimate 100 words and you
could have very simple conversations to
get your message across and it might be
sometimes like foot hurts need cream
something like this and they'll go oh
you and then they'll hold up this thing
in you go yes yes yeah then if you've
accomplished a goal you've made
something happen and you've seen that
language has a real purpose then it's
not just showing up not just learning
words it really is from exchanging ideas
and making fact making things occur that
wouldn't have occurred without you being
able to do that it really boosts your
confidence yes absolutely you know what
I do with my with my students the first
time I say look you don't know anything
of the language let's have a
conversation say what do you mean a
conversation yes literally start having
a conversation we build upon that and
they say wow I had a conversation for 20
minutes without knowing almost anything
and this gives them the confidence that
they can do it yes actually easier than
people think what if you didn't do what
never happened
you can spend I think it's
understandable if you want to have input
before output but the the problem is
that you can have input for the rest of
your life but it's not going to
magically transforms itself into output
the world you know you've noticed this
amazing thing we're talking yesterday
yesterday we're talking about well
taking a stroll the beautiful proud
about the fact that you can read but you
might not understand you might
understand what I'll be able to read you
can speak but not understand you can
understand what I'll speak if you
develop these abilities at different
times at different speeds right yeah in
fact this is one thing I would the one
possible criticism of a lot of courses
is that they are based on reading and
writing and you can become a really
fantastic reader and a really fantastic
writer and develop no conversational
ability absolutely staying locked in
your bedroom with the textbooks is it
great that you're studying greatly
you're learning but he's impact on your
communication ability can be quite
minimal so are you were saying just to
conclude you were say for example that
you told this lady to go clean the
ice-cream shop we get some ice cream
what happens to to a person who let's
say a native English speaker who lives
in the
States but he wants he's learning your
time he can't go too deep well yeah
there's a lot of Italians but let's
suppose that he doesn't have Italians
just where he lives what would you
advise do you use the internet to use
Skype I hope you Skype actually went
because I I've taken this idea with a
few other languages now and what I if
I'm going to some farming country I went
to Bhutan and decided to learn some
Bhutan the edo antic Cambodian aside
some Cambodia song that it's called
Bhutanese dumb cat and I decided to
learn a bit of these languages and just
enough to be able to have very very
simple conversations and I was able to
find people on skype and just say okay I
don't know anything and then we really
affected somebody's trying to learn a
few words of these languages but the
only the only thing I will say is that
on skype you have to be very careful
that the other person doesn't think that
they are a teacher when you're a student
that's not a good one yeah it's really a
language is Chinese trying to develop
your conversational ability or language
ability not just for them to read in a
stressful situation of being a language
teacher even if they've got no
experience with it so try to keep the
focus on developing the language
communication you can teach yourself the
grammar and the vocabulary but
developing the language skill the
communication skills the biggest lesser
of today is like language about
communication right teacher well it is
if less you go yeah even the can be
people whose whole job is whose whole
purpose is just to read novels or
something in a foreign language other
poetry but for most of us we're learning
a language I believe so we can talk to
people absolutely
what can I say thanks a bunch and hikes
from Prague okay